Okay, so I want to make a band object. I don't see any
new object thing. Alright, can you help get me started here, Sam?
>> Yeah, so, if you go to the elements tab, that's
where you can find all the stuff that you can create.
>> Okay, object. Oh, and I can just drag it. Oh,
that was cool. Okay, so create new object, I'm going to call it
band. Fill out the rest. Okay. So I've gotten my object
with the default fields and then kind of just drag fields onto
it, too.
>> Yeah. So these are almost all of the same
fields that you have in the Field Creation Wizard. A
couple have been taken out, but for the most part
they're all here. Just drag the fields directly onto the object.
>> Cool. So, I did it. I added all
these different fields. It's got a couple of check boxes,
a couple of picklists for set time and genre,
phone number, text for the Twitter handle. It's pretty easy.
>> Great, looks good.